the legacy of final fantasy lives on in  final fantasy type-0 HD the world of  audience is as epic and engaging as any  from the series just waiting to be  explored in ways you will know and enjoy  there might even be a few surprises  and of course some of your old friends  will be there to help you find your way  I am the military operation organization  and got in such a Styx experts logo for  short Kapow nothing in my way you'll  need your wits about you to defeat some  of final fantasies most famous and  formidable foes  two  and  customization and character growth are  key to victory  powerful monsters called Eidolons are  also back to do your bidding  the gears are turning faster than I had  imagined and because only this universe  whose essence is centered in the beauty  value and power of the crystals that  offers a tale truly worthy of a  legendary Final Fantasy series  that's about enough  you  you